* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
Ein Bergbauernhof
am Abhang des Pilatus.
Gemeinde Schwarzenberg.
Hier fliesst der Giessbach,
Objekt eines erbitterten Streits.
Bauer Peter Ott gegen die Behörden,
so läuft das schon seit 30 Jahren.
Es ist eine, wie's scheint,
endlose Geschichte,
die dem Bauern den Namen
Behördenschreck eingetragen hat.
Die Behörden
wurden sicher etwas abgeschreckt.
Ich kann mich nur
an jene Fälle erinnern,
in denen Richter gesagt haben,
sie seien schon 25 Jahre im Amt,
aber einen solchen
hätten sie noch nie gehabt.
Und ... Ich muss sagen, es ist Zeit,
dass sie nun einen haben.
Jemand, der sie
auf den richtigen Weg bringt.
Da ist immer ein Strafverfahren, ein
anstehender Prozess oder ein Urteil,
gegen das sich Peter Ott wehrt,
wehren muss.
Ich bin Schweizer.
Ein Schweizer sagt: "Ich bin da."
"Und ich bin einfach ... da."
Ich kämpfe nicht für mehr Macht,
um etwas zu erobern.
Aber das, was mir gehört,
zu dem will ich schauen.
Und ich will, dass es mir gehört.
Gegen alle anderen Einwirkungen
wehre ich mich.
Das Giessbachtobel
bildet auf einer Länge von 600 m
die Grenze zum Hof von Peter Ott -
eine unstete Grenze,
denn der Wildbach reisst immer wieder
Stücke vom Land weg.
Für den zuständigen Kanton Luzern
wäre eine umfassende Bauchverbauung
viel zu teuer.
Deshalb macht es der Bauer selbst,
was er aber nicht darf.
In 30 Jahren zähmte er den Bach,
legte das Bachbett höher,
um die Energie zu bremsen.
Von hier an
machte ich das ganze Bachbett.
Die Rutsche, die runterkamen,
habe ich hier aufgehalten.
Es war bestimmt ca. 20 m tiefer,
als ich kam.
Jeden Steinbrocken hier
hat er versetzt,
selbst riesige Felsstücke,
Hunderte Tonnen schwer,
hat er mit Seilwinden
in die richtige Lage gebracht.
Doch ganz stoppen
lässt sich die Erosion nicht.
Noch immer stürzen Teile
seines Landes ins Tobel
und weiteres Material
hängt in der Luft.
Das ist eigentlich alles mein Land,
das ...
... schon weg ist.
Mein Land reichte ca. 20 m weiter.
Der jahrzehntelange Kampf
des Peter Ott:
ein verbotener Kampf,
sagt der Kanton,
weil der Bauer widerrechtlich
ein öffentliches Gewässer verändere.
Es war im Jahr 1995.
Der Streit mit dem Kanton
war damals bereits voll entbrannt.
Mit einem Bagger ist man stärker
als mit einer Schreibmaschine
gegen die Steine
und gegen das Holz und den Bach.
Kurz nach diesen Aufnahmen musste
Peter Ott erstmals ins Gefängnis.
Seine Frau
war nun auf dem Bergbauernhof
auf sich allein gestellt.
Ich verstehe einfach nicht,
dass man mir einfach
meinen Mann wegnehmen darf.
Besonders für die Kinder
waren es belastende Erfahrungen:
der Vater im Gefängnis,
Getuschel in der Schule.
Josi Ott hatte 1965
einen eigenwilligen Mann geheiratet.
Nach acht Tagen konnte Peter Ott
das Zentralgefängnis in Luzern
wieder verlassen,
noch immer in den Stallkleidern,
die er bei seiner Verhaftung
getragen hatte.
Im Gefängnis hatte ich alles,
was ich zu Hause nicht habe.
Ich konnte fernsehen,
Radio hören, Zeitung lesen,
duschen, rasieren ...
Wie in einem Hotel.
Der Bach ist ein schöner Nachbar.
Er bekam noch nie eine Strafanzeige,
er hat mir noch nie etwas angetan.
Er sagte einfach mal wieder:
"Ich will hier durch."
"Diesen Stein nehme ich mit, weil
du ihn ungenügend befestigt hat."
Ich möchte
keinen anderen Nachbarn als ihn.
mit keinem Bundesrat tauschen.
Und mit Kantonsräten sowieso nicht.
Und mit Gemeinderäten noch weniger.
Der Vater von Peter Ott war Bauer
und Wuhrmeister im Kanton Schwyz.
Von diesem hatte er gelernt, wie
mit wilden Bächen zu verfahren ist,
z.B. wie abrutschende Hänge
zu stabilisieren sind.
Die Tanne soll in eine Runse
gesetzt werden,
um die Erosion aufzuhalten.
"Die natürlichste Verbauung,
die man überhaupt machen kann",
sagt Peter Ott.
Allerdings
klappt es nicht auf Anhieb,
auch weil der Bagger etwas
überfordert ist von der Aufgabe.
Für diese Arbeit
ist er einfach zu klein.
Klein genug.
Der Siebentönner,
den sie mir weggenommen haben,
wäre für diese Arbeit gut.
Damit könnte man die schwereren
und grösseren Bäume nehmen.
Peter Ott
musste in den vergangenen Jahrzehnten
dreimal ins Gefängnis,
teils mehrere Monate.
Die Behörden
haben ihm elf Bagger weggenommen
und noch mehr Kettensägen.
Das ist der zwölfte Bagger,
der hier ist.
Und eben ...
Im Grunde genommen
machen sie einfach Blödsinn.
Sie würden mir viel gescheiter
mit dem Bagger helfen,
als mir die Maschinen wegzunehmen.
Und nun
ist auch der zwölfte Bagger weg.
Frische Raupenspuren vom Vorabend,
als Polizisten
das schwere Gefährt geholt haben
und mit diesem auch gleich Peter Ott.
Heute bringen sie
den Bergbauern zurück.
Er verbrachte die Nacht
in einer Polizeizelle.
Bei der Verhaftung
hatte es eine Rangelei gegeben.
Der alte Mann hatte eine Krücke
gegen einen Polizisten erhoben.
Ermittelt
wird nun auch wegen Drohung.
Bei einer Hausdurchsuchung
wird nach Waffen gesucht,
gefunden werden keine.
Ich konnte nicht gut schlafen,
weil mir der Arm schmerzte,
den die Polizisten mir
verdreht hatten.
Und die Hand von den Handschellen.
Das hat mich ...
Sohn Urs ist zum Vater hochgekommen.
Er war am Vortag
bei der Verhaftung dabei.
Ich bin ziemlich erschrocken,
dass es wegen eines kleinen Baggers
ein solches Theater gab.
Und ähm, ja ...
Als ich kam,
lag der Vater am Boden und jammerte,
seine Schulter schmerze ...
Da fragt man sich schon.
Wegen eines kleinen Scheissbaggers
mit einem 75-Jährigen Mann
ein solches Riesentheater
abziehen ...
Man fragt sich, ob es auf der Welt
nicht andere Sorgen gibt.
Ja.
Ich finde,
man hätte das in der heutigen Zeit
auch im Büro klären können.
In den Büros
arbeiten doch so viele Menschen.
Der Hof Oberlangenehrlen.
1979 ist das Ehepaar Ott
ins jahrhundertealte Haus eingezogen.
Es sind
sehr einfache Wohnverhältnisse,
in denen sieben Kinder
grossgezogen wurden,
sechs Buben und ein Mädchen.
Und da war immer dieser Streit.
Bei der Verbauung des Baches
hatte Peter Ott gelegentlich auch
Bäume aus dem nächsten Wald geholt,
aus Wäldern der Nachbarn.
Im Dorf
hat er daher nicht viele Freunde.
Er weiss, dass er Dinge tut,
die nicht erlaubt sind.
Dadurch wurde er so.
Er ist kein bösartiger.
Er hat seine besonderen Gesetze,
die sind aber nirgends
niedergeschrieben,
das ist unser Problem.
Wenn man Bilanz ziehen möchte,
ist es eher so,
dass sein Verhalten,
wie er das Problem löst,
die Existenz und seine Familie
viel stärker gefährdet,
als das "sein" Bach,
wie er ihn nennt, je machen könnte.
Josi Ott, Peters Ehefrau,
wohnt schon seit einiger Zeit
unten in Schwarzenberg.
Die Umstände, v.a. der ewige Streit
um den Giessbach,
haben sie krank gemacht.
Ich habe ihn
auch lange nicht verstanden.
Ich sagte ihm oft, dass die Familie
an erster Stelle stehen sollte.
Dann der Betrieb und dann der Bach.
Bei ihm war es aber andersrum.
Bei ihm kommt zuerst der Bach,
dann der Bach.
Die Familie ist ihm ...
Da habe ich schon schwer gelitten.
Die Familie ...
Wenn man den Bach
nicht hätte machen müssen,
hätten wir mehr Komfort gehabt,
es wäre leichter gewesen.
Das ist ...
Aber eben, man muss sich halt schon
fragen, was zuerst kommt.
Das Land, das vom Bach weggezerrt
wurde oder immer noch wird,
ist nicht mehr anzusetzen.
Es ist fast nicht mehr möglich,
dass man es zurückholen könnte.
Aber ein solches Haus
mit diesem Komfort
kann man jederzeit wieder machen.
Regelmässig erhält Josi Ott
Besuch von ihrem Mann,
und gelegentlich fährt die Frau
nach oben, macht dort den Haushalt.
Die Distanz hat den beiden gutgetan,
hat neue Nähe geschaffen.
Den Rummel um ihren Mann jedoch,
während Jahrzehnten in zahllosen
Zeitungsartikeln ausgebreitet,
den vermisst sie nicht.
Mit der Zeit ist man ...
Die Jungen würden sagen:
"Alles am Arsch vorbei!"
Er war der Held
und hat sich auch als Held gefühlt.
Wie es uns erging ...
Ist er ein Held?
- In gewissem Sinn sicher.
Das macht ihm keiner nach,
einen Bach
im Alleingang zu verbauen.
Das Giessbachtobel gibt nie Ruhe.
Erneut hat Peter Ott
ein Stück Land verloren.
Dieser Rutsch
ist nun frisch heruntergekommen.
Wenn man bei dieser Runse
Büsche angepflanzt hätte,
wäre das nicht nicht passiert.
Das ist wertvolles Material,
das wir eigentlich
für die Wiederbewaldung bräuchten.
Das ist guter Humus.
Wenn es regnet, geht er in den Bach
und dann ins Meer,
dann haben wir ihn verloren.
Der fehlt dann genau hier.
* Sanfte E-Gitarrenklänge *
Und das ist Peter Otts Methode,
den Rutschhang zu beruhigen,
wiederzubewalden:
Holzpaletten
werden mit Langheu bedeckt,
Samen schlagen aus,
verfestigen die Grundlage.
Schliesslich wachsen Weiden daraus.
Der Kanton jedoch sagt,
das sei eine Deponie.
Ja, das sagen sie.
Aber das geht ein paar Jahre so,
dann sieht man es nicht mehr,
weil es überwachsen ist.
Die Paletten sind ja aus Holz,
das ist waldeigen.
Das vermodert
in den nächsten 20-30 Jahren.
Daraus entsteht Humus.
Den will man im Wald haben.
Die Methode mit den Holzpaletten
hat in den letzten Jahren
bereits grosse Grünflächen
im Abhang geschaffen.
Und doch dreht sich der aktuelle
Streit mit dem Kanton um die Frage,
ob das eine Deponie sei.
30 Jahre nun
wogt diese Auseinandersetzung
mit Polizeieinsätzen, Verurteilungen
und auch gelegentlichen Freisprüchen.
Seit einigen Jahren muss sich beim
Kanton Michiel Fehr damit befassen.
Warum bloss ist hier nie ein Ende
dieser unseligen Geschichte geglückt?
Persönlich anerkenne ich
die grosse Erfahrung von Peter Ott.
Er ist seit vielen Jahren
in diesem Thema drin.
Er beobachtet sehr gut,
was abgeht und funktioniert.
Das war für mich auch
die Motivation,
um mit ihm einen einvernehmlichen
Weg, eine Lösung zu suchen.
Leider merkten wir,
dass einige seiner Lösungen
gesetzeswidrig sind,
z.B. die Ablagerungen im Hang
oder das Zuführen von Material,
was per Waldgesetz
schlicht verboten ist.
Zwei Jahre zuvor hatte auch
der Kanton einen Anlauf genommen,
um das Giessbachtobel zu bewalden.
Die farbigen Pfosten
markieren Stellen,
wo Gruppen kleiner Lärchen
gepflanzt worden sind.
Das ist das Einzige,
was noch nicht kaputtgegangen ist.
Das kommt jetzt.
Es ist noch nicht kaputtgegangen,
aber es wurde auch nie
von einem Steinschlag getroffen.
Dank dieses Baues.
Und dank
des Steinschlagschutzdammes,
den ich dort oben angelegt habe.
Doch lieber kommt Peter Ott
an den Bach runter,
um nach kleinen Tierchen
Ausschau zu halten, Kaulquappen.
Ja, das ist einfach beruhigend.
Wenn ich wieder von der Polizei
angegriffen werde,
denke ich mir jeweils,
wenn ich ausraste:
"Danach gehe ich wieder runter
und schaue mir das an."
So beruhige ich mich
und bin wieder zufrieden.
* Donnern *
Eines
der gefürchteten Pilatus-Gewitter
lässt den Giessbach anschwellen.
Das lockt Peter Ott
an den Rand der Schlucht.
Wenn es in der Fluh regnet,
dauert es etwa 1 Std.,
bis das Wasser hier ist.
Ich komme immer her und sehe,
wo man etwas machen sollte,
wo es nicht hält oder was gut ist.
* Sanfte E-Gitarrenklänge *
Es ist die neueste Baustelle
des Peter Ott:
Die Zufahrtsstrasse zum Hof droht
im Giessbachtobel zu verschwinden.
Nach der Methode,
die er vom Vater gelernt hat,
will Ott die rutschende Stelle
stabilisieren.
Nur, diese Bauarbeiten
sind bewilligungspflichtig,
und bis jetzt hat sich Ott
mit den Gemeindebehörden
über die Massnahmen
nicht einigen können.
Sie wollen es immer noch verbieten.
Ich sagte immer:
"Wenn ihr macht,
dass mir nichts mehr wegrutscht,
höre ich sofort auf."
"Aber ihr müsst etwas tun."
"Ihr müsst das tun."
Wir sind immer noch im Clinch.
Nun macht der Bauer halt nur
die notwendigsten Sicherungsarbeiten,
damit ihm die Strasse
nicht ganz abhandenkommt.
Dienlich
ist dabei ein Occassion-Bagger,
den er sich nach Beschlagnahmung
des letzten wieder angeschafft hat.
Wie finanziert der Bergbauer
diese vielen Baggerkäufe?
Man lebt einfach etwas bescheidener.
Wir gehen nicht in die Ferien.
Vieles kann man sich nicht leisten,
was andere sich leisten können.
In einigen Wochen wird sich
die Polizei auch diesen Bagger holen.
Immerhin, bis dann wird die Strasse
zumindest notdürftig repariert sein.
Die Verbauung des Giessbachtobels
hätte den Kanton Millionen gekostet.
Unverhältnismässig viel, allein
wegen eines Bergbauernbetriebs.
Und so tat es der Bergbauer
notgedrungen selbst,
und das nicht mal schlecht.
Was ihn jedoch
zum Gesetzesbrecher machte.
Alle Beteiligten
wollen richtig handeln,
das Resultat
ist ein Versagen der Vernunft.
Der einsame Kampf
konnte Peter Ott nicht verbittern.
Dafür haben sie mich gestraft,
dafür kam ich ins Gefängnis.
Aber ich bereue überhaupt nichts.
Ich bin sogar stolz auf alles,
was ich gemacht habe.
Jetzt wächst das.
Das Land hat Ruhe, auch der Bach
sieht relativ gut aus.
Ich wüsste nicht,
wie man es besser machen könnte.
Die Kühe
sind von der Alp zurückgekehrt.
Jetzt haben wir sie
wenigstens wieder.
Es ist kurzweiliger,
wenn die Tiere hier sind.
Sie haben mir schon gefehlt. Ja.
Es ist ... wie wenn man etwas
nicht hat, das hierher gehört.
* Unverständliches Plaudern *
Und der Streit dauert an.
Es ist eine Eingabe
ans Bundesgericht zu verfassen.
Ein Lebenskampf, in Ordnern verpackt.
Dokumente des Scheiterns - und es
half auch kein göttlicher Beistand:
In drei Jahrzehnten ist es nicht
gelungen, einen Ausgleich zu finden
zwischen dem legitimen Bedürfnis
des Bergbauern,
sich vor Landverlust zu schützen,
und dem Anspruch des Staates
auf Durchsetzung seiner Regeln.
Wie lange will Peter Ott
noch weitermachen?
Die Staatsanwältin
auf dem Amtsstatthalteramt
hat mich das kürzlich auch gefragt.
Ich sagte:
"Wir streiten
schon seit gut 30 Jahren,
auf 20 Jahre mehr oder weniger
kommt es auch nicht mehr darauf an."
* Sanfte E-Gitarrenklänge *